>> Hi, I'm Dushyanth Narayanan,
I'm a researcher at
Microsoft Research in
Cambridge in the UK,
and I'm going to tell
you about FaRM and A1,
which me and my team have been
working on over
the last five years.
If we look at distributed
computing platforms today,
we have good platforms for
batch computation at scale,
such as Cosmos or MapReduce,
which can run large computations
over thousands of machines,
for minutes to hours.
We also have good platforms
that can provide low latency,
but they don't scale out,
and FaRM is a platform for
providing low latency at scale.
FaRM makes it easy to build
low latency scale out
applications by hiding the things
that make distributed
applications hard,
which is concurrency, failures,
and data distribution.
So, FaRM abstracts this away and
provides the programmer with
the abstraction of
a single machine
that pulls the resources
of the entire cluster,
runs transactions one at
a time, and doesn't fail.
The way we do this is
by providing
distributed transactions
with strict
serializability which has
very strong consistency,
and high availability.
Distributed transactions
are a very old idea,
but in the past, people
thought they wouldn't scale,
and that they wouldn't
perform well.
In FaRM, we showed that
within the data center,
we can have distributed
transactions,
with very strong consistency,
high availability, and
great performance.
To achieve this, we leverage
the hardware that's present
in our Azure data centers today.
So, plentiful and cheap DRAM
means we can keep
the working set of applications
in memory for low latency.
Lithium ion batteries
integrated into racks,
let us make this memory
non-volatile at low cost.
Fast RDMA networking, let us
cut the cost of scale out.
Now, the hardware alone doesn't
give us this performance.
So, there was
a huge amount of work to
get the performance out
of the hardware which
involved redesigning
the communication stack,
and new distributed
systems protocols
such as a novel transaction
commit protocol.
A result of this work,
we have amazing scalability,
high throughput and low latency,
and extremely high availability.
So, for an example, we can
recover to full throughput from
a failure in 67 milliseconds
in this experiment,
which is less time than
some systems take to commit
a single transaction even when
they don't have failures.
So, FaRM, as a research idea
started about
five years ago, right?
We did foundational research on
FaRM over the next two years,
and over the last three years,
we've been pushing
FaRM to production
as well as building A1,
a graph database that
we're exposing to
internal customers in
Microsoft because there
was a huge need for
a good graph platform
with high performance,
scalability and
high availability.
So, where we are now is
that we've just gone
live with our first scenario
for this graph platform.
My colleague Alex is
going to talk about that.
>> Hi, my name is Alex Shamis,
and I work with Dushyanth and
a bunch of other people to
build FaRM and then
our partner product called A1.
A1 is a distributed
graph database that
we've built to help accelerate
applications that need
to use graphs and have
to have consistent graph
but are too big to
fit one application.
I'll show an example of
what we've been able to do,
and what we've been able to
put into production using
the technologies that Dushyanth
just talked about in FaRM,
along with all the other
people that worked
on FaRM and the A1 product.
So, using a Bing query,
there was recently a news article
saying that Russell Wilson is
the most sacked football
player in the NFL.
So, an interesting
question would be,
so who who sacks Russell Wilson
so much and who are
the statistics on this?
So, we can type into Bing,
who sacked Russell
Wilson the most?
Then in seconds, we
get the results.
We get this result,
showing that the people that have
sacked Russell Wilson the
most is Robert Quinn.
This query, once it
comes to our back end,
executes a six hop graph query
that does 22,000 reads,
and were able to perform this
in tens of milliseconds.
So, this is just a small example
of what we would be able
to do with FaRM and A1,
and put into production
with Bing. Thank you.